[Music]
[Music]
I have to sing I have to play the music
it's it's not just in me it is me when
life gets me down I play my guitar the
rest of the world may follow the rules
but I must follow my heart do you know
that feeling like there's a song in the
air and it's playing just for you
[Music]
never underestimate the power of music
no one was going to hand me my future it
was up to me to reach for my dream grab
it tight and make it come true
all right moving the
you gotta stay with me boy we are
[Music]
- season two choosen you're all really
out there
[Music]
Mira Mira they're setting up for tonight
the music competition for dia de Muertos
you want to be like your hero you should
sign up huh my family would freak look
if you're too scared then well have fun
making shoes come on
what did Eric rules always say seize
your moment show me what you got
muchacho I'll be your first audience I
[Music]
know your tricks mariachi What did he
say to you
he was just showing me his guitar shame
on you you keep away from him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cuz she's in the Chosin you're all
really out there you thought we weren't
well I don't know I thought it might
have been one of those made-up things
that add up still kids like vitamins
Miguel
vitamins are a real thing for long
thinking maybe they could be no photo on
and a friends are no crossing the bridge
you know what I'm just gonna zip right
over you wouldn't even
[Music]
okay who cares
dump our great I don't know what I do if
no one hood up my photo I will eat
around the house just like mama Imelda
did no music don't music only family in
Mexico who hates music and my family is
fine with them but me be back by lunch
me mama hey ma like the rest of my
family
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's you you you are that boy that the
one who came from the land of the living
anyone has been talking about why have
you come here I'm again your your
great-great grandson
I have a great-great grandson the winner
gets to play for the muchacho
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once every year our ancestors come back
to our world to see family and friends
but no living person
has ever visited their world until now
[Music]
all right moving the
[Music]
you got to stay with me boy
[Music]
you mind
me gain what is going on remind me how I
know you they're your family
[Music]
we have to get you back home
welcome anything to declare as a matter
of fact yes
oh it's you you're gonna get me in
trouble daddy something could hear me I
wish someone wanted to hear me other
than you I know I'm not supposed to love
music no music no music but my
great-grandma Coco's father was the
greatest musician of all time bah even
esto de la Cruz one day he left with his
guitar and never returned my family
thinks music is occurs
great-great-grandfather none of them
understand me I'm supposed to play music
alright losing there
[Music]
[Music]
no skeletons don't walk like that that's
how you walk
no I don't there's no one left in the
living world who remembers you you
disappear from this world but you can
change that we've gotta find my trick
your grandpa you've got a do it by
sunrise will Happy's at Severns you'll
be stuck here forever oh I'm a big fan
never forget how much your family loves
you
it's almost sunrise one cannot deny who
one is meant to be that doesn't have any
hair and I don't have a nose and yet
here we are
Kommandant
[Music]
[Music]
stay with me welcome to the land of
declare as a matter of fact yes you
better get home before sunrise or you'll
be stuck here
[Music]
that's our ticket muchacho
enjoy the party hey I'm a big man do you
mind
what are you doing I'm walking like a
skeleton no skeletons don't walk like
that it's how you walk no I don't stop
it doesn't have any hair and I don't
have a nose and yet here we are every
year grandkids cousins pretty much
everyone gets together pretty much I
mean that's what I thought you said the
animals windows has begun it's the one
night of the year
our ancestors can come visit us at
Elmira been one of those made up things
okay I was just a night is about family
I am not like the rest of my family
there's something that makes me
different great-great-grandfather I want
to be a musician just like you all right
moving uh I'm sorry welcome to the land
of your ancestors
regale where your family just illusions
your I gotta get home before sunrise or
you'll be stuck there forever Oh
[Music]
it's so time
you my boy are meant to be a musician I
must follow my heart
[Music]
I am trying to save your life rescue me
game something snacker more than you
think
sorry
may have our differences but nothing's
more important than family
I'm proud we're family
[Music]
oh wait you go it's just bunting never
named a street dog they'll follow you
forever now go get my shoe
[Music]